ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla seconda
parte della posta di sonia io direi
a questo punto corsa ti seguo di sé con
questa forza che che ci contraddistingue
per un pochino
quali sono i consigli che altri ci
dicano che tanto ci vogliono chiedere io
[Musica]
è un argomento molto attuale la tua
diplomazia continua i giornali
telegiornali hanno parlato di una
situazione analoga ma che è arrivata
magari a degli estremi follia perché è
una persona matura grande sa è vero che
oggi quindicenni 14 dimostrano 30
scusate ma questo capita anche per le
ragazze però insomma i rapporti sempre
con un minore con tutte le conseguenze
poi che insomma ricevono quindi essere
una buona insegnante a sé una buona mica
ci sta però credo che poi uno deve anche
fare un bel passo indietro e insomma
direzionare i propri interessi e motivi
su altre cose insomma non credo che sia
una situazione sicuramente difficile per
lei assume nessuno vuole bravissima per
carità a volte ci lasciamo trascinare
certi da certi sentimenti emozioni che è
difficile no mettere un bel freno però
qui bisogna anche far funzionare un po
il cervello
cambia strada anche perché come detto tu
qua si sta parlando veramente di un
qualcosa che potrebbe essere grave
qualora si dovessero superare
determinati limiti a livello legale
professionale ti faccio proprio un
discorso d'amico che non fare
semplicissimo troppo spesso nato altan
denti infatti non so se riesci a capire
quello questo dice djokovic è gonfiato
sotto voglio sbattere la testa al muro
niente ho bisogno di un po di conforto
che cosa posso fare ti sei mai solo
altro dente del giudizio la pasta in
facendo da ore il gonfiore e tutto è
disperata comunque grazie per avermi
ascoltato ciao
condividiamo ti siamo vicini e solidali
e che hanno tolti 20 quindi bravo sai
quelle cose che servono per congelare il
furto da miccoli
nella borsa frigo quando vai in giro
magari non proprio a diretto contatto
con la faccia perché da porta il
gonfiore seppure gestione quindi no però
magari avvolto in un panno già comunque
il ghiaccio attutisce un pochino il
dolore scusa non aiuta anche quelle cose
di people are etti ghiaccioli così da
tenere
ed estetici la bocca abbiamo chiare che
neanche la lingua aver capito quella per
conto suo e se tutto gonfiate sfruttato
la situazione dovrebbe tipo prendersi un
lecca lecca con una tazza sotto così che
ci sta la destra inguardabile e se serve
alla cosa va benissimo
guarisci presto così si dice seguono
professioni nera io ero già io gente va
avanti senza un augurio senza nato in
bocca al lupo io sono una ragazza molta
attenzione che si butta giù per
praticamente tutti senza nessun motivo
sono stata baciata paio di volte e devo
ancora finire la scuola quando avrei
dovuto già finire una non lo so io ho
sempre paura di non essere mai
abbastanza di non arrivare a fare i miei
sogni
quindi il consiglio potrebbe magari
tammy utile per carina questa la chiamo
paura di vincere
quando tu fai di tutto per auto saab
haute arti automaticamente tu non hai
paura di perdere perché stai perdendo
già stai facendo di tutto per quindi la
paura quella di provare e non riuscirci
credo che questa pigrizia sia veramente
il tuo problema perché il tuo buttarti
giù molto probabilmente è legato al
fatto che ti aspetti che le cose siano
più semplici siano più facili non
debbano essere per forza frutto di un
pochino di sudore e il mio invito è
quello di buttarti un pochino più nella
mischia e non aver paura di fallire
perché falliscono tutti quanti ma chi
fallisce male per mal intendo in una
mera sbagliata e chi non prova proprio e
dire oh cavolo ce l'ho fatta stavolta ci
possono essere anche queste come si dice
queste battaglie perse perché non tutti
insomma abbiamo gli stessi tempi lo
stesso modo di crescere no di affrontare
le cose
questi stop di un'ora servono anche per
diventare un po più forti il problema è
che nella vita così come ogni giorno
deve ricordare di respirare per campare
perché altrimenti si respira una volta
ogni tanto non ti andrà comunque bene e
la stessa cosa specialmente se si
ambiziosa dai fuoco a questa cosa è
continuare anche con la scuola insomma
benissimo in bocca al lupo o lo sa io
sto per dire perché l'hanno imparato ho
imparato
tutti dicono vive il lupo però io dico
sempre grazie dicono sbagli devi dire
viva il lupo io ho detto grazie
ero speciale come ti amo ma anche nel
cuore ti ringrazio in bocca al lupo
centrale in bocca al lupo sono una
ragazza non c'è il mare non penso che
non sia solo un mio problema ma c'erano
parecchie ragazze musulmane che sono
nati in italia o all'estero
il fatto che sono affezionato ad una
persona che non è dalla mitezza che
rigenera ovviamente i miei genitori
unirebbero vedermi con la persona della
mise serie gta ramadan su come la
prenderebbero set per serio sapere che
io ho deciso
desidero di stare con una persona a
prescindere dalla loro religione o
magari anche per loro adesso non la
prenderebbero molto bene un saluto a te
perché ora è accaduto nella pressione
ricambiamo in realtà se ci pensi tutti
quanti i figli di persone praticanti in
maniera importante sono molto più simili
di quanto non si pensi anche se uno
crede in alla uno crede in diretta sono
molto più simili tra di loro di quanto
non si creda perché perché vivono questo
pressing di quelli che sono i dogmi che
gli vengono imposte
c'è un momento in cui ami la mamma il
papà e c'è un momento in cui il loro
amore un amore che ti nutre ti fa bene
c'è un momento in cui ami te stesso o te
stessa in questo caso che quell amore
che ti nutre che tifa band di un pochino
d'arte puo essere un po forte perché poi
le dice anche che non sa come i genitori
possano reagire
può darsi vorrei che invece una
situazione del genere conoscendo questa
persona possa ma anche cambiare idea
anche perché insomma voglio dire mica
per forza deve essere ci deve essere un
atteggiamento sempre così di divieto e
inoltre io magari a prendere pure più
morbida pensare magari a invitare
qualche amico che possa essere un'altra
religione in modo magari pian piano
della pillola l'ultima scelta quella fai
tu perché comunque è una scelta che crea
attrito che sicuramente non è
facilissima da fare
in bocca al lupo ciao ragazzi abbia
oramai dico ciao ragazzi perché fra te e
guglielmo l'ospite tuo cugino che
ascolta gli altri ma tutti quanti
insieme ragazzi già un e book qualche ti
vorrei che ter non è una parola di
conforto per me ma più che altro per mia
zia si guarda tutti i tuoi video mia zia
roberts lei dalla sicilia è salita su a
milano a studiare e infermieristica dire
23 parolin e di conforto penso che gli
farebbe tanto piacere
ciao ragazzi un bacio alla zia cacciamo
gli auguri in bocca al lupo si imbocca
al lupo
so che è difficile stare lontano da casa
difficilmente riuscire a fare quello che
fai
che fai tu ma se me lo stai facendo per
te carino questo nipote meraviglioso sì
sì ma ormai ormai lui roberta sia
roberta si chiama così roberta veramente
in bocca in bocca in bocca al lupo
angelo ormai sei un habituè quindi
figurati quando vuoi per il prossimo
tema che aspettiamo ha da poco scoperto
che la mia migliore amica nonché
testimoni di nozze ha tradito il suo
attuale fidanzato nonché il mio marito
con una sua ex vecchia fiamma fingendo
di avere un lavoro il weekend che la
portava fuori città al mese per
frequentarsi con questo tipo non so se
mi interessa con le spalle al muro
oppure se lasciare che sia il tempo in
qualche modo tirerà fuori questi
scheletri dall'armadio
grazie mille maggioni a questo è un gran
bel dilemma
non direi no devi dare delle piccole
indizi che l'altro in qualche modo a
volte le cose noi vogliamo vedere perché
ci fanno male magari uno lo sa ma
secondo te lo dice a perché me ne detto
cioè quelle situazioni molto ambivalenti
inglese con i denti il complice e rosa
e invece che la prendo un mezzo cercando
di adatto tu che faresti
io credo che stare davanti a una ragazza
che tu sai che si è creata un alibi per
vedersi con un'altra persona non è che
questa qui una sera ubriaca ha fatto una
cavolata che comunque un errore se tu
sei una sua amica io quello che farei è
sedermi con lei dire che stai facendo
che cos'è che vuoi ti fai una scelta
cos'è che ti manca rosa critico di
follia vede a volte no nella vita alle
cose che dobbiamo veramente complicare
la gra in una roba assurda però credo
anche che un amico debba farti ragionare
le banche spingerti a capire che cos'è
che vuoi non si può avere tutto
no l'amica certo la deve affrontare ma
per lei per te e per lui è solamente
parlandone che che riuscirai a tirar
fuori questa cosa senza però come dicevi
tu parti troppo coinvolgere entrare in
quelle dinamiche ambigue rientri anche
tu in questo circolo noi diventi il
cattivo rovini l'amicizia perché hai
detto che l'evento di colpo titoli fra
due rosa l'amica del cuore trovo giusto
che giustamente si se a muso duro
frank fin da quando ero piccola mio
nonno non si è mai presentato non mi ha
mai dato affetto
non ho mai fatto il nome in pratica solo
ultimamente si vuole riavvicinare a me
solo che io non me la sento perché
appunto è sparito per tutta la mia vita
non so come comportarmi perché non si
merita niente solo che io non sono dal
cuore di ghiaccio e rischiare di cedere
solito ha paura di rimanere di nuovo
deluso air aster rimpianto di non aver
fatto o di non aver detto anche le cose
che siano il cuore che secondo me a
volte uno deve anche liberarsi no cioè
io ce l'ho con te perché non è fatto
questo come per dirlo perché a questo
punto 1 sta meglio e poi questi rapporti
comunque rinascono sotto una forma
diversa c'è più sincerità magari anche
l'educazione che uno ha avuto no
nell'infanzia tante persone magari le
persone più anziane era o magari che non
c'era la semplicità
anche nell'abbracciare nipoti
celerissimo e se non siamo noi i primi a
rompere il ghiaccio perché io ho fatto
quindi mi rendo conto che con altre
persone però ho visto quali il
cambiamento che poi abbracciarsi diventa
una cosa naturale l'inizio uno resta
così veniva le cose che vanno anche
insegnate e anche in questo caso questo
nonno
vabbè si è comportato così avrà avuto i
suoi motivi ma anche rene ai suoi perché
magari è arrabbiata e c'è un po degli lo
dica però per quelle risposte per poter
solamente esatto e magari fatti seguire
per non sciogliersi perché a volte il
bisogno ci fa dimenticare ci fanno passi
da gelo capitò alla fornace infatti
magari aiutare dei tuoi genitori o da
non so se un fratello una sorella o
comunque qualcuno che ti permetta
comunque di analizzare la situazione con
relazionalità che se ti ha mandato il
messaggio perché ci di area questo nome
che sa fare riallacciare mestiere esatto
bravissima parlargli
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo tema
io sonia vi ringrazio ma innanzitutto
per la disponibilità ma grazie della tua
vita
la tua disponibilità ragazzi è stato lo
shooting più lungo della storia non
smettevamo di parlare quindi ti
ringrazio di cuore per la tua
disponibilità grazie a the go io
ringrazio naturalmente tutte le persone
che ci hanno scritto
naturalmente come si dice in bocca al
lupo a tutti bocca al lupo ma che vita
sempre il lupo e ringrazio voi che ci
avete seguito vi invito a seguire sonia
sotto vi lascio tutti quanti insomma i
poi poi link iniziando questa anche se
anche sui social
ovvio che gli amici ma non ci riesci
capita vi incoraggio in questo senso la
vecchia ma quindi quella spinta che resa
ti farà diventare chiara ferrari non fai
niente ragazzino ci vediamo la prossima
settimana sempre con un altro video vi
mando un bacio ciao ciao
[Musica]